Bonjour My Fell Brother Welcome to the
[Music]
of
exp Oil
[Applause]
paint
[Music]
gangang
sugg [
Music]
name
Oh [
Music]
War More [
cl
ze Bel
[Music]
mozo
do we do the
technique
magnifik
Look Now  is time
for eh we
start
bl Le
milk
Now It's
Time
[Music]
Petra
[Music] [
Music]
TR
fist Le
fist fist Le fist
[Music]
ehk Time for
Cin
[Music]
magn P
[Applause]
[Music]
de
gco
Fin
signat
TR
It YouTube
eh gang
bang Here let's take a look at It if you
want to win this masterpiece Leave a
like and eh Why a comment Why you think
you should win It suggest what else you
want me to do in Art of Fan Art And  I'll
see you Bros in the next one St awesome
bress This Is The sest Thing
Ever let get that ding ding dong in
there damn Them shk
[Music]
balls yeah